something's not right in pittsburgh as
evidenced by the fact that they got
shellacked by the browns on sunday night
mike tomlin met with the media for his
end of season press conference we will
now not see or hear from him for months
here's what tomlin had to say yesterday
on possible changes including their
quarterback ben roethlisberger
i'd start first and foremost by saying
you know obviously didn't anticipate
being here
um
in this position
um disappointed uh by it
um understand that
you know um we better make some changes
in terms of the things that we do we
better look at every aspect of it um
schematics personnel
approach to business uh i'm committed to
that you know i'm not gonna maintain
status quo and
and hope that the outcome changes that's
you know that's the definition of
insanity do you think
that it's realistic that ben will be
back given the the uh cap implications
you know
you know i don't i don't i don't have a
clear assessment of of the overall
impact of the cap ramifications so i
might not have a
direct answer to your question but i
think it's reasonable to to assume that
there's a chance that he's going to be
back certainly um the the depths of the
ramifications of the cap discussions um
i am not privy to as i sit here right
now
we can help you out mike 41.25 million
dollar cap charge if ben roethlisberger
plays next year under the final year of
his contract 22.25 million if he retires
there's a 19 million dollar gap between
the two i have an item at pft that
breaks down how they could reduce that
cap number and they could get it down
you know in the range of 26 million it's
still at least going to be 22.25 the
question is
how much closer to 22.25 or 41.25 will
it be by virtue of an extension that
takes money to be paid this year and
spreads it out over multiple years but
chris here's the big requirement
roethlisberger has to go along with it
yeah if roethlisberger at some point
says i just want to honor my contract i
just want to play out my contract i have
one year left on my contract i'm going
to honor the terms of it the signal
there is hey you're going to carry 41.25
or you're going to cut me and and this
is where it gets
potentially delicate we we touched on
this briefly on monday but it was more
about the game
if he retires if he says i retire the
steelers have every right under the cba
to come to him and say you us
owe us 12 and a half million dollars in
unearned money that we've paid you in
the form of a signing bonus they have an
absolute right to do it the lions did it
the calvin johnson i remember saying
five years ago calvin johnson should not
retire he should force the lions to cut
him he's got a bloated cap number force
them to cut him then you don't owe them
anything and secondly
you can go wherever you want to go
remember there was noise from time to
time about maybe calvin johnson wants to
play for the patriots yeah still under
contract with the lions he's on the
reserve retired list if you're cut you
can do whatever you want so if you're
ben roethlisberger and you're thinking
maybe i'm done
your better course may be to play this
out
and say
let's see if they carry 41.25 million on
their cap as of march 17 when the total
cap may be 175 chris so that there's
potential here
for an awkward parting of the ways
driven by roethlisberger being a little
passive aggressive and saying
i'm just going to honor my contract
which means i'm not playing your
extension game so you can have a lower
cap number and take the balance of that
cap charge later well i i feel like if
he does that then he's telling us he's
done though right i mean that that to me
would be the big thing because
that that number is ludicrous next year
that something needs to be done
i mean a big man wants to come back and
actually have a chance to be successful
you know and maybe they can resign a bud
dupree and maybe they can you know help
out that offensive line and get a
top-notch running back and things like
that then i he should and he wants to go
out you know into the sunset then he
should look at every avenue and trying
to help them find a way to lower that
number for next year
but if it's like hey he just wants to
retire then yeah that probably is the
move where he just goes okay no i'm
going to play this out cut me you got to
cut me i'm not just going to retire and
then unless they says i'm going to
retire and then they just go hey you
keep the 12 million dollars which is i
think they would do anyways i don't
think they're going to make ben
roethlisberger write a check i know but
the lions did it to calvin johnson
now i know there's and the lions did it
for barry sanders yeah so that's stupid
i don't know sorry lions you were stupid
in both of those occasions
andrew luck and jim irsay have it more
right in that way they worked out a deal
right they worked out i think some money
went back to jim erskine okay worked out
a deal yeah um because his was
unexpected and it was earlier in the
contract this is the last year and ben's
gonna gonna be 39 coming up and i
th the other side of this and
look we got we got to be honest in our
assessment we said this before this
isn't a surprise
look ben we all have an ego ben likes a
little attention ben sees peyton manning
finish his career with another team
brett favre finished his career with
another team guys who played while he's
played
tom brady finishes his career with
another team phillip rivers finishes his
career with another team
what if ben's thinking maybe i just want
to have the ability maybe maybe i just
want to be
not that he does the tb12 method but but
who knows what happens in november of
2021.
contending team has an injury here comes
ben riding in on a white horse to save
the day you've got the flexibility to do
that if they cut you so you're right if
he says i just want to honor my contract
the signal is i'm done in pittsburgh and
maybe done for good and they won't just
say keep the 12 and a half million
dollars and i think the best way to do
it if if that's what he wants to do
the most productive way to do it chris
is for his agent to go to the team and
say
look
he wants to retire but he doesn't want
to pay back the 12 and a half million so
we've got two ways we can do this
um he can retire and you can agree not
to take back the money or
he can force you to take a 41.25 million
dollar cap hit as of march 17. and yeah
he'll come back for one more year and
you got to pay him another 19 million
you got to deal with that cap charge all
year long what do you prefer and i think
that if they negotiate the right way
right maybe he can't walk away without
having to pay back the money if that's
what he wants i i i would agree with you
there i would think that's kind of how
that conversation goes down i i think
big ben going to another football team
is off the table uh justin and just my
assessment as the football player i
think you'd have to be
you know rivers brady
you know they were still making plays
last year
we limped into the finish line with with
with big ben
you know
it's it's like i think he has one more
year left in him definitely so that's
where i think it's a little different
you know i i don't think people are
gonna come away watching film and going
man
we need more of those four yard passes
that big ben throws you know that's
where he still can win and do that
but as big ben or you heard mike tomlin
talk about there
there's got to be a
major shift in how they approach the
game on the offensive side of the ball
they have no chance of going to a super
bowl if they're going to play the same
style they played this year next year
with big bed like a guy who can't move
and an arm is declining and we're going
to ask him to throw the ball 45 times a
game that makes no sense if you want to
get the most out of big ben they better
get into running the football and
winning the line of scrimmage that way
being able to protect him play action
passes a little bit like we're seeing
you know brady and tampa they went all
in on protecting him and that to me is
what you'd have to do if you want to
make it work for one more year with big
ben and if you're going to make dramatic
changes to the offense and all these
things thomas was talking about maybe
the time has come to move on to a new
quarterback so uh as to the idea of him
playing for another team keep this in
mind yeah in 2010 when he went through
the stuff in georgia and got suspended
by the nfl he was reviled in pittsburgh
they were done with him and they were
right they were talking about trade him
to the raiders back in 2010 that he was
hated and he's rebuilt that
so that's all the more reason to not
squander that goodwill and go play for
another team
especially an afc team that would be
potentially competing with the steelers
that's not going to be good for anybody
if he does that and it's amazing how how
he turned around his image his
reputation and just the extent to which
people like him or don't like him in
pittsburgh no it is amazing and one
thing i just want to bring this up
because i'd love to hear you i thought
about this last night when i saw the
text for the rundown and all that but
like at what point does the nfl maybe
think about
like there's a franchise tag how about a
legends tag like if you've played with a
team for 12 years or so you know you get
a certain amount of your salary cap cut
off so we don't have to cut these
legends just because of salary cap
casualties and things like that i i i'm
not saying it necessarily pertains to
this but it's just something i think
about at times
it's a shame we run out guys older in
the league sometimes who can still play
but they're run out really because of
the salary cap number
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports